welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham in episode 7 of
She-Hulk just gave us potentially our
first physical look at MCU vampires with
the introduction of saracen I don't know
if you noticed but I'm stuck on the fact
that for a vampire this dude seems
pretty chill out in the daylight is
saracen truly just a vampire wannabe
like Blonsky suggests or could he truly
be a bloodsucker of the Damned it's
almost Halloween baby and I have a
Creature Feature theory that might set
the tone for next year's highly
anticipated blade outing in episode 7 of
She-Hulk attorney at law Jen is
introduced to a handful of d-list super
villains from the comics after getting
trapped in Emile blonski's summer
Twilights Wellness Retreat without any
cell service she spends a good majority
of the episode with man ball El Aguila
wrecker and the porcupine but Terence
Klaus Gothic saracen was truly the most
unexpected addition to the MCU as
surprised as I was to see a potential
vampire in the flesh this isn't the
first mention of vampires in the MCU
aside from that blade reveal at the end
of eternals in Kingo joking that his
assistant initially thought he was an
immortal night thing we've heard joking
mentions of vampires in one division
Thor Ragnarok and even Loki's time
variants Authority called them out it
was only a matter of time before they
showed up on screen in the comics there
are two characters that go by the Alias
saracen a Merc who tussles with the
Punisher and in 90s blade villain who is
only in three Comics vampire saracen is
real old he is one of the first vampires
to exist making him part of a class of
vampires known as the ancient saracen's
comic history amounts to mostly
summoning the Demonic Reaper to hunt
down blade although he himself never
actually battles the Vampire Hunter on
page it's pretty clear that the saracen
and She-Hulk is mostly a complete
reimagination of the character but I
don't know I think that his name alone
suggests that TV saracen could be an
actual vampire saracen's appearance
makes confirming that fact a little
murky he says he craves blood multiple
times but his ability to stand
unprotected in the daylight proves that
he isn't inhibited by one of the
greatest downsides to being vampiric not
everyone sparkles in the sun like Edward
Colin okay some of of them have to carry
around little umbrellas and stay away
from garlic bread on pizza night being
able to withstand UV rays is unheard of
for True pure-blooded vampires and blade
is the only MCU Vamp who has this
distinction blade status as a day Walker
is a signature part of his character so
I find it unlikely that other day
Walkers would be established in the MCU
Cannon before blade even has a proper
appearance I did see some speculation
online that saracen is Blade's son in
part due to his UV immunity and in part
due to saracen's comments about his
father wanting his blood or he wanted
her blood no not that man that's not
talking about blood not everybody's your
dad don't talk about my dad well this
certainly is an interesting Theory I
don't think that it's the case as far as
the source material goes blades only
confirm child is his daughter Brielle
and she's a fairly recent addition to
Comic Canon also unless the MCU is
introducing an aged blade who's been
part vampire for decades and I'll see
him having a son in his Undead 30s there
are times when I'm up so late that it
Cycles back to early and I have a hard
time sleeping with Rosie finger down I'm
creeping into my bedroom it used to be
the case that when that would happen I'd
grab a blue blocks blackout sleep mask
but now blue blocks has become on charge
so I grab a bond charge sleep mask
instead I know it sounds weird to say
I'm bad at sleeping but I am something
super horrifying about me is that I
sleep with my eyes open but if I'm using
boncharge's sleep mask that doesn't
matter it blocks out 100 of incoming
light it's very soft and has adjustable
eye cups and an adjustable strap for the
perfect fit it works for belly side and
back sleepers okay it's super
comfortable and I can confirm that I can
see absolutely nothing if I were napping
this would be perfect yay now I can see
again boncharge ships worldwide and have
other great products like low blue light
bulbs red light therapy devices and blue
light classes go to boncharge.com new
rockstars and use coupon code new
rockstars to save 20 that's
b-o-n-c-h-a-r-g.com new rockstars and
use coupon code new rockstars to save 20
so how can sarisin be true to his comic
namesake and be a vampire while still
being able to soak up the sun well he
could be a pseudo vampire sort of like
the acclaimed and highly revered
Blockbuster Mega star morbius and his
vampire powers could come from a
non-magical source that prevents him
from facing the side effects of his
vampire curse additionally it's possible
that he had vampiric powers but lost
them buckle up though is stat cause I
got a wild theory that saracen is a real
vampire entering blonsky's retreat in
the aftermath of the events of
Multiverse of Madness you see in Marvel
Comics lore the origins of vampirism
date back to 18 500 BC back when
Atlantis was still above sea level
during this period in Atlantis a group
of sorcerers known as the dark holders
practice the dark arts of cathon yep the
very same cathon that corrupted the
Scarlet witch with the dark holes one of
the dark holders varnia became the first
vampire lord in history and all
pureblood vampires in Marvel descend
from him this connection and link to the
dark hold is not only where all Marvel
vampires get their powers but it's also
where these creatures of the night get
their weaknesses and the this darkhold
vampire connection isn't just dated lore
either last year there was a whole
darkhold comic mini series that touched
on the connection between cathon and the
vampires because Marvel vampires are so
intrinsically tied to the dark hold it's
interesting that blade is being
introduced into the MCU after the
Scarlet Witch deleted the dark hold from
the Multiverse because saracen
potentially be a Smoking Gun that hints
towards Wanda not only eliminating the
dark hold but actually erasing its
influence from reality did we just get a
no more mutants moment but for vampires
and not even know it what if the
namesake saracen is actually important
because that character has somehow been
cosmically altered imagine if previous
to Multiverse of Madness MCU saracen was
more in line with his comic counterpart
an ancient evil pure-blooded vampire
what if Wanda House of Ved vampires and
other influences of the dark hold from
the Multiverse when she took down Mount
wundergore I think it's entirely
possible that he suddenly lost his
vampiric curse in that moment and for
the first time in Millennia ceased his
unquenchable bloodthirst this could
explain why he needed to go to bad guy
rehab now that he isn't physically
dependent on drinking blood he's
questioning his humanity and working
towards deprogramming his blood drinking
habit formed over thousands of years he
still claims that he's a vampire because
that was his identity for 99.99999 of
his life but others might have a hard
time believing it because he no longer
can prove it to be true if this is the
case then what does this mean for blade
in his upcoming movie seems a little
unlikely that you can make a movie about
a half vampire vampire hunter in a world
where vampires have stopped existing
well not of 2023's Blade starts planting
the seeds of cathon's counter-offends to
Wanda's dark hole Destruction play
setting up a potential plot line that
interconnects blade in the midnight Suns
with Wanda's widely presumed return
saracen doesn't seem to have forgotten
that he was a vampire in this scenario
so it's possible that other Vampires
will miss their powers and find a way to
re-establish a connection with the dark
force that made them Immortal also if
Marvel really wants to dive into Blade's
comic Roots they might even briefly
explore the period of time before blade
was part vampire every good vampire
movie's gotta have a flashback otherwise
how would we know that Edward Cohen
almost died of the Spanish Flu in 1918
or that Tom Cruise's stat really wanted
to be an actor before Magnus turned him
against his will or that Stuart Townsend
Lestat awoke Akasha Queen of the Damned
with the pure power of rock and roll or
that Jonathan Lipnicki had to destroy a
cursed amulet to turn his buddy Rudolph
and his family back into humans prior to
Wesley snipes's Blade movies comic blade
was just a vampire hunter with
resistance to vampire bites to make the
character more in line with his version
from the movie The Comics went full
morbin time on blade to transform him
into the badass daywalker we all know
and love making rehearsala Ali's blade a
human turned half vampire over the
course of the film could be a small way
to differentiate the mcu's blade from
the original films similar to the way
that the MCU approached their Tom
Holland Spider-Man remakes coupled with
my theory that saracen lost his powers
when the dark hold took over I really
think that we could be dealing with the
undead already opening an unexpected
doorway for blade to enter where's comes
doors I'm wrong and Sarazen is just
another Twilight fan girl follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at whitneypuppy
follow new Rockstar subscribe to new
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love and thanks for
watching bye
[Music]